well it's a crackdown at the border on
transparency
the white house still refusing to allow
reporters into packed migrant facilities
like the one you're seeing right now
and senator ted cruz slashing clashing
with what appears to be a biden
administration staffer
over filming the cramped conditions
watch this
you don't want the pictures taken the
rules are arbitrary and they're designed
to keep the american people
dignity and respectful are you
respecting the rights of these this is
not a sir
please don't treat the people you're
right and this is a dangerous
place please don't treat them and your
policies unfortunately are trying to
hide them i understand you are
instructed
when eighteen senators came down the
people give them dignity i respect them
and i wanna fix this situation
we all wanna
the overcrowding at border facilities is
set to get worse with officials
expecting the surge in child migrants
to last for seven months and as for
transparency
white house press secretary jinsaki is
promising to let the cameras in
at this point in terms of allowing
access
to border patrol facilities for
reporters you are being less transparent
than the trump administration
the trump administration was turning
away kids at the border sending them
back on the treacherous journey
or they were ripping kids from the arms
of their parents we're not doing that
i we are committed to allowing cameras
into the border patrol facilities so
much to talk about
tucker i want to start with you you know
dc journalists very well
and while many of them have said they're
frustrated they're not furious
about the access why do you think that
is
well because it's their candidate i mean
they just they just got him elected so i
mean they can't start criticizing him
now
i think there are a lot of details we
can't see because cameras aren't let in
i think the big picture is really clear
many thousands of people are arriving
into this country
most of them will not leave all of them
according to joe biden on track to
become citizens so there are two points
that people are not considering and i
think they should be
one is the allocation of political power
we talk about voting rights in a
democracy
demographics equals political power so
if you
change the demographics of the country
if you
bring in a lot more people without the
consent to the government you dilute the
political power of the people who live
here
that's a really meaningful thing and
we're talking huge numbers i started in
journalism 30 years ago 30 years ago
there were a hundred
million fewer people living in the
united states there are now 100 million
california alone had 10 million fewer
people was a completely different place
a much better place
so the question is how many people do
you want to live here we have about 350
million we think
there are massive environmental effects
of overcrowding nature
actually bears the burden of that at a
certain point that the natural landscape
does and all of us who live here do
so at what point do we say it's not
about whether these are deserving people
i think they mostly probably are and all
nice people
no one's debating that but what about
the people who already live here
like it seems like we have enough people
in the country why is nobody saying that
i
i think i will start saying that because
i think it's true i saw over the weekend
that on friday it was estimated that
one thousand migrant migrant children
crossed over
in one day that were turned over to cbp
and were processed
jesse waters could you please listen to
some sound from senator lankford of
oklahoma
get your reaction on the other side this
is one of the areas
that the media is not allowed to be able
to come into that's why i wanted to be
able to be here
to be able to see it and say this is the
thing that biden does not want you to
see
is that literally people walk across the
border they check in here
and they are all released 100 of the
people that are here tonight will be
released
so this is absolutely an open border
situation
you know if the media is not going to be
allowed in the senators have gone and
they're releasing these videos jesse
the politicians are becoming the press
and the press have become
politicians can we take the emmy from
cuomo and give it to ted cruz
i mean he looked like geraldo rivera
down there kicking down doors like that
on the border maybe he's trying out for
fox news prime time or something but
he shouldn't be doing gonzo journalism
down there at the border
where are the network news crews and
correspondents
joe biden just took the press's first
amendment away from him
freedom of the press and they didn't
even put up a fight
he said you can't cover your own
government at the border and the press
complied
remember they said how brave they were
for four years while donald trump
declared war on the media there was no
war they had more access
than they've ever had and now joe biden
says heal
and they kneel down like good obedient
puppy dogs
the covet excuse it's preposterous
i mean let's ask fouchy can a cameraman
from 50 feet
away point his lens at kids in cages
is that enough social distancing to
cover a scandal
we want to follow the science it looks
like
joe biden's triggered this crisis and
this corrupt media is now helping him
cover it up because in a way he's
complicit with a modern day
slave trade run by the cartels the dhs
biden's own dhs is leaking to axios it
says joe's planning
on keeping 50 000 kids in cages per
month
for basically the rest of the year so
any teenager that comes across
from all over the world through mexico
gets to stay
and if you grab a minor and come across
a majority of them
get to stay that's not a policy
for immigration that's just absorbing
illegal immigration
so right now the only people that are
making out
are the cartels the american people are
getting hurt
one so the officials themselves are the
ones saying that this migrant
surge especially with children could
last for another seven months but do you
get any sense
that the administration is grasping the
enormity of that
while two polls that came out today abc
news and reuters both showed
the president cratering on this issue
while doing very well in other issues on
covert response even the economy but on
this issue he is losing support
he's using some support still at 60
percent uh in some of these polls it's
unbelievable his ratings his approval
rating stays pretty high
but you know to to jesse's point maybe
you know
senator lankford senator cruz are trying
out for prime time
because what are they doing down there
pretending to be photographers and
journalists
that why don't they get back to
washington in their day job and buckle
down
in congress work to come up with a
solution to this
problem instead of trying to play
politics
and i guess they're out there trying to
do damage to biden let's be clear
biden's been in his press conference
last week totally
clear and transparent he's not letting
the press in yet because that's not his
priority his priority
is making sure that there are enough
facilities and enough
people to handle to adjudicate the cases
of these people who are applying for
amnesty under american law
and he doesn't want to increase human
suffering of these children people 16
and under
you're seeing their thermal blankets
obviously those are cramped
quarters but what you're seeing is that
they are in fact opening more
facilities in large numbers to try to
deal with this problem
and they're also now starting to work
with countries in latin america
honduras el salvador to try to stop the
flow
and i might add they're also dealing
with border security you had a hundred
thousand people
arrested at the border in the month of
february
so that's the reality bob is dealing
with a big surge it could be
even bigger than the surges that trump
saw your point to me dana was
about the incredible number that might
come over the next few months
those numbers those statistics come out
of administration
reports right so that's why i asked it
degan is that the enormity of the
problem
those are the ones that they know will
come across or they estimate will come
across it's not all the ones
but how can the how can the senators
go forward and work on legislation with
when the administration is not willing
to change policy on this issue
well exactly and to suggest that these
republican senators
are part of the problem is absolutely
ludicrous juan
it is laughable the reason that this is
happening is because the
biden administration rolled back the
trump policies that were working
without thinking about the consequences
or maybe they did
and just didn't care that they were
putting young people and children in
harm's way
remain in mexico for asylum seekers gone
safe third country agreements
gone catch and release back one sheriff
telling of a texas border town telling
the new york post
that there's so many agents that have
been transferred from patrol duty to
processing stations
that basically the border is wide
open we talk about transparency
we're talking about daylight finally
because the
the press is not doing its job the press
sold
this lot to the american people and now
they're embarrassed and burying their
heads in the sand
and the only daylight is coming from the
likes of ted cruz
and he's facing off with this woman who
has the audacity
to basically act like it's her border or
biden's border
not the united states border and she's
telling him to go away she did have some
of her little talking points so she was
up to date on the glossary clearly sent
out by the white house
she said i ask you to respect these
people give them dignity
what dignity they're laying out laying
in cramped quarters because of the biden
administration
it this is not a zoo sir so she's
clearly up to date on the talking points
from this white house
however the problem is is the talking
points have gotten away from him
because even a deplorable with a
toothpick between his teeth
and a bible under his arm can see what
the hell is going on
at the u.s border it is disgusting the
position that these children have
been put in and the only time you're
going to see kamala harris down there
until it looks like a playground at a
montessori school
and those kids are running around
playing soccer
degan what did you have for lunch
because
i get some of that i've been out of work
for two and a half weeks i have a lot to
say
i'm sorry i ran my mouth shut up the
rest of the show
we are so glad you're here it's great to
have you back